dans l'actualité ce soir michel
fourniret est condamné à la perpétuité
incompressible la peine maximale du code
pénal perpétuité également pour son
épouse monique olivier avec 28 ans de
période de sûreté
les intempéries le centre de la france a
été pris sous des trombes d'eau la nuit
dernière l'indre et la crds eux sont en
crue violent orage aussi sur le sud
ouest
peut-être la fin du mystère du front
anti radar un homme de 29 ans est entre
la vie et la mort après l'explosion de
sa bombe artisanale il se revendiquait
de ce groupuscule le retournement de
l'immobilier le marché du neuf s'est
effondré au premier trimestre 2008 il
faut désormais près d'un an pour vendre
une maison
yannick noah va quitter la france à
l'automne la personnalité préférée des
français va s'installer à new york pour
au moins deux ans l'ancien champion
devenu chanteur sera notre invité à la
fin de ce journal
enfin du football avec la surprise
passée gomis l'attaquant de
saint-etienne est retenu par raymond
domenech pour l'euro-2008 cissé et
landreau ne sont pas sélectionnés
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous
après deux mois de débats le rideau est
donc tombé cet après midi sur le procès
fourniret
sans surprise la cour d'assises a suivi
les réquisitions de l'avocat général
à 66 ans le tueur en série ne devrait
plus quitté la prison jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie sur place à charleville mézières
dominique verdeilhan bruno vignais une
nuit à la caserne 24 heures de délibéré
les jurés viennent de répondre aux 75
questions
un verdict tant attendu que tout le
monde dewilde avance au même moment les
deux accusés arrive au palais ils ne se
font aucune illusion sur le verdict d'
or c'est la cohue médiatique et
populaire
on veut les voir pour la dernière fois
michel fourniret et monique olivier
condamnés à la perpétuité
l'un sans aménagement de peine l'autre à
une période de sûreté de 28 ans un
verdict qui apaise les parents des
victimes
après huit semaines de procès
on avait peur qu'elle est qu'elle est
moins bon elle peut encore faire appel
mais on n'y croit pas trop
et ils ne font plus de mal à personne
c'est surtout ça qui est important
il faut s'arrêter de poser des questions
parce qu'on en sait suffisamment et je
pense que la douleur on l'a partagée
voilà stocks
côtière bull renault un face à face
tendu de deux mois qui a permis aussi
aux victimes survivantes de fourniret de
se déculpabiliser
aujourd'hui je me sens vraiment lieu et
j'ai vraiment envie de continuer de
montrer que son voeu est que la vie
continue et est encore plein de belles
choses
un verdict qui définit les rôles dans
ces crimes à quatre mains michel
fourniret et auteure principale monique
olivier sa complice monique olivier
c'est pas un diable c'est une criminelle
c'est un être humain et elle est
défendable et en tout cas il me semble
que ça ça a été entendu un procès qui
s'achève par un voeu du président de la
cour d'assises qu'il n'y ait pas d'appel
afin dit-il que chacun puisse se
retrouver dans le silence et
l'apaisement mais pour certaines
victimes la justice les a fait patienter
pendant 21 ans des maisons inondées des
rivières en crue les orages violents et
les fortes pluies continuent à faire des
dégâts en france
la nuit dernière c'est le centre du pays
qui a été touché dans l'indre un
reportage françois privat alain
darrigrand cette voiture vient
d'emprunter une voie sur berge inondées
je vais vous partez avec le courant là
probablement incrédule face à tant
d'inconscience les passants met près
d'une minute à réagir
la conductrice semble choquer perdu si
personne n'intervient elle est emportée
par la creuse
jusqu'en fin d'après midi le niveau de
la rivière a continué à monter lentement
2 m 20 au dessus de la côte d'alert les
bas quartiers du blanc ont les pieds
dans l'eau certains habitants quittent
leurs maisons
ici la creuse s'est invité dans le salon
de ce locataire qui vient tout juste
d'emménager sakho lure
le service des clous de la direction
départementale de l'équipement évalue le
débit de la rivière 500 mètres cubes
seconde
est-ce que c'est exceptionnel ça pour la
saison c'est pas mal oui pourquoi pas on
est quand même fort mais là début juin
et que la d'année c'est cependant lui
toute la décrue devrait s'amorcer dans
le courant de la nuit
mais on annonce de nouvelles
précipitations pour demain aux
inondations aussi en savoie la fonte des
neiges a ajouté aux fortes pluies de ces
dernières heures a provoqué des crues
des routes ont été coupées à noter aussi
qu'un peu plus au sud près de gap le
barrage de serre ponçon bat des records
de remplissage des f a évacué une partie
de l'eau pour faire baisser le niveau et
puis attention si vous habitez le sud
ouest de violents orages étaient prévues
en cette soirée situation paradoxale
ailleurs en europe on bat des records de
chaleur c'est le cas en autriche 34° 8
canicule aussi ici en sicile 39 degrés à
palerme avec vous le voyez déjà
d'importants feux de forêt plusieurs
maisons ont dû être évacuées
en france je vous le disais en titre
c'est peut-être la fin de l'énigme du
front anti radar on en avait parlé ici
même une mystérieuse fraction
nationaliste armée révolutionnaire avait
revendiqué une dizaine d'attentats
contre des radars fixes en région
parisienne elle réclamait 4 millions
d'euros et l'expulsion des clandestins
et bien un membre présumé de ce
groupuscule s'est grièvement blessé la
nuit dernière en manipulant un engin
explosif
il s'agit d'un employé de la poste il
est âgé de 29 ans audrey goutard mady
diarra
une dizaine d'hommes cagoulés des
enquêteurs de la division antiterroriste
ils ont perquisitionné toute la matinée
dans l'appartement dévasté les faits se
sont produits vers minuit chez frédéric
rabiller un postier de 29 ans l'homme
manipuler des explosifs quand le drame
s'est produit
il est ce soir entre la vie et la mort
mais avant de s'évanouir il a déclaré
aux pompiers être membre de la fraction
antiradars la fnar un mystérieux groupe
qui a revendiqué une dizaine d'attentats
contre des radars en région parisienne
en moins d'un an
les voisins de la victime en sont
abasourdis
c'est quelqu'un que je dise quoi quand
les parents croyaient disait bonjour il
faisait ça redescend route
le post est discret travaillé au bureau
de tri de nanterre ici aussi ses
collègues décrivent un homme silencieux
sauf lorsqu'il parlait politique et
penser que oui c'était ce qu'il fallait
tout faire sauter bon après tout faire
sauter ça veut pas dire grand chose on
peut l'entendre 200 fois par jour sans
que pour autant cela s'incarne un jour
dans une action chez frédéric rabiller
les enquêteurs ont découvert le même
explosif que celui utilisé pour les
attentats les cartes routières avec la
situation des radars et la même corde
que celle utilisée pour accrocher les
bombes
ils doivent maintenant déterminer si
l'homme a agi seul tout à fait possible
qu'il soit entré dans cette logique
d'attentats seul et sans bénéficier ou
créer un réseau des réponses viendront
peut-être de l'entourage du blessé ce
matin de ses amis a été placé en garde à
vue il éclairera peut-être les
enquêteurs sur les motivations du
postier la justice encore en bref le
gendarme a mises en examen à draguignan
après la mort d'un homme qui s'évadait a
été remise en liberté et placé sous
contrôle judiciaire
décision du juge des libertés en
incarcération avait provoqué
l'indignation de ses collègues des
images signées virgili ados on en sait
un peu plus sur la réforme des taxis
notamment à paris la ministre de
l'intérieur michèle alliot marie
annoncent que leur nombre augmentera de
1200 dès la fin de cette année par
ailleurs les voitures seront mieux
repérables grâce à un système bi colore
en jeans aux homards et claire denis
jusqu'à présent pour repérer un taxi en
france il n'y avait que ça une petite
plaque lumineuse plus ou moins
compréhensible dès l'an prochain
ils sont bicolores et à chaque ville ses
couleurs
le choix n'est pas arrêté mais voici une
petite simulation le toit sera surmontée
d'un panneau a grandi et plus claire feu
vert taxi libre feu rouge taxi occuper
le nouveau taxi parisien le voici
l'expérience avait été brièvement mené
dans les rues de la capitale au milieu
des années 80 une couleur unique pour
les taxis
cela rappelle les fameux yellow cabs new
yorkais où les coccinelles mexicaine
avantage plus de confusion possible
entre les taxis officiels et les taxis
clandestins
autre nouveauté l'expérimentation
pendant un an d'une voie réservée entre
l'aéroport de roissy et le centre de
paris course à tarif unique
elle devrait libérer 600 taxis aux
heures de pointe ce n'est pas pour
déplaire à ces touristes brésiliens
monde 16 britten et chauffeurs il
connaît bien ce trajet et ses
perpétuelles embouteillages de france
c'est habituel approche du périph
jusqu'à 1h45 pour faire 30 km alors
selon lui tout le monde y trouvera son
compte
les deux gagnants nous en tant que
rapidité pour déposer le client et pour
aller en recharge est un hôte et le
client va hyper est un peu moins cher
l'état s'y verront également leur nombre
augmenter d'un quart à paris 1200 taxi
cette année s'y rajoutent les gens vont
crever pas déjà comme ça on a frappé
notre gasoil de 16000 dans les rues de
la capitale
ils passeront à 20 milles avant 2012
autre chantier la loi de modernisation
économique c'est en fin de semaine ou en
début de semaine prochaine qu'elle sera
discuté à l'assemblée
elle vise notamment à renforcer la
concurrence dans la distribution pour
essayer de faire baisser les prix et à
renforcer par exemple l'installation de
ce que l'on appelle les hard discounts
vous connaissez sans doute ses magasins
un peu moins accueillants mais souvent
moins cher
quelles sont leurs recettes pour faire
baisser les prix y at il une différence
avec les supermarchés classiques enquête
caroline thébaux à nitry boire à la
sortie de ce hard discount c'est
toujours le même argument qu'avancent
les clients la qualité la qualité est
bonne et c'est moins cher qu'ailleurs
c'est tout le lait par exemple 17
centimes de moi sur un litre de lait
quand vous avez des enfants à la maison
ça vaut le coup rien qu'en magasin cette
enseigne allemande peut faire jusqu'à
15% d'économies sur les coûts
tout est calculé au plus juste décor
spartiate minimum de lumière pas de
musique pour ne pas payer de droits
d'auteur et sur les palettes des cartons
prêts avances comme ils disent il suffit
de tirer dessus et sassou appelons ça
facilite le temps de mise en rayon et au
lieu de mètres à environ 40 minutes dans
une grande surface on arrive à faire une
palette en 20 minutes à peu près car
carla marquez se charge aussi des
commandes du ménage parfois et de la
caisse conséquence il y à ici deux fois
moins de salariés qu'en supermarché et
la direction fait tout pour encaisser
plus dix clients en principe le produit
va passer être scannés tout simplement
et n'ont pas retourné
étant donné que nous sur chacun de leurs
produits ont fait l'effort de mettre
plusieurs jeunes femmes mais dans le
discount le choix est très limité voici
l'homme qui sélectionne les produits
vendus en magasin neuf cent cinquante
références maximum contre 8000 en
supermarché il les fait fabriquer sans
aucun marketing ni publicité
xavi - produits maxime 2 cl besoin est
un peu différencié dans le marché mais
pour chaque besoin il ya un produit et
c'est là où il faut que nous nous
commettons pas d'erreur et que le choix
de du rapport prix qualité qu'il est le
bon en france le discount représente à
peine 14% du marché de la grande
distribution
deux fois moins qu'en allemagne la loi
de modernisation de l'économie pourrait
favoriser l'implantation de nouveaux
magasins la grève des pêcheurs contre le
carburant cher marque légèrement le pas
dans le nord à calais à dunkerque ou
encore ici à boulogne le mouvement est
suspendu jusqu'à la réunion des
ministres européens à la fin du mois de
juin
en revanche d'autres pêcheurs en
méditerranée ou encore sur la façade
atlantique continuent à protester avec
des barrages filtrants ou des opérations
commandos dans les grandes surfaces
images ici de la rochelle et surtout on
l'évoquait déjà ces derniers jours
d'autres catégories prennent leur
c'est le cas des agriculteurs valérie le
rouge david bres le gazole devenu trop
cher
c'est à la sueur que roulent les
tracteurs du nord aujourd'hui à lille
les jeunes agriculteurs ont défilé ainsi
pour réclamer un carburant complètement
défiscalisées et même en partie prise en
charge par l'état
le demande se rapproche en tout cas des
marins pêcheurs pour un carburant
professionnel qui peut lui permettre
vraiment de produire à un coup juste
pour les producteurs et pour les
consommateurs tout simplement d'une
ambiance plus violente dans l'hérault
l'affrontement était rapide mais musclée
que les agriculteurs avaient bloqué le
dépôt pétrolier de frontignan résultat
un blessé chez des crs un autre chez les
paysans toujours les mêmes slogans mais
cette fois à toulouse les jeunes
agriculteurs bloquent aussi de dépôts de
carburant depuis ce matin et ils sont
bien déterminés à obtenir un coup de
pouce du gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est très significatif en
bloc aura jusqu'à demain soir et s'il ya
aucune réponse et verra plus loin
la hausse du pétrole ce n'est pas
seulement sur le gazole qu'elle se
répercute pour les agriculteurs c'est
aussi sur le prix des engrais issus de
la pétrochimie pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée sur une exploitation de 100
hectares l'augmentation est de à peu
près quinze mille euros
autre action en bretagne où ici sur la
rocade de bordeaux
une opération escargot ou les routiers
se sont joints aux agriculteurs pour
protester contre la hausse du gazole et
puis on l'a indiqué dès hier de plus en
plus de pays sont touchés par ces
manifestations contre la flambée des
prix du carburant
la bulgarie s'est ajouté à la liste avec
ses premiers blocages de camionneurs à
sofia à noter aussi s'est ruée vers les
stations service à taïwan où le
gouvernement vient d'annoncer que le
prix de l'essence allait être relevé
d'un coup pour tenir compte de la hausse
des cours du pétrole
des milliers d'automobilistes vous le
voyez on fait la queue toute la nuit
pour remplir leurs réservoirs en france
l'éducation c'est le mois prochain que
se tiendra le procès de ce professeur
qui avait giflé un élève
après avoir été insulté la faire vous
vous en souvenez avait fait couler
beaucoup d'encre à l'heure où l'on parle
beaucoup de la revalorisation du métier
d'enseignant elle rappelle que
l'incivilité et parfois les violences
verbales ou physiques sont l'un les
motifs de stress et de désarroi
d'autant que les professeurs n'y sont
pas préparés comment faire face
comment anticiper certaines académies
comme celles de versailles ont pris les
devants
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé mallory ahounou olivier robert
c'était en décembre dernier au tribunal
pour enfants de l'île juger un élève de
15 ans qui après une exclusion avait
agressé cette jeune enseignante elle
exprimait alors son désarroi toujours
fraîche lycée je me sens comme
vulnérable chez jeu pas repris le
travail donc ça montre comment que
un point du professionnel et quand
quelque chose qui était rompu
aujourd'hui cécile marco garde de ses
élèves les cartes de soutien mais n'a
pas repris son poste au lycée elle
enseigne à l'hôpital en course
individuelle
le souvenir de l'agression est encore
trop cuisant j'ai senti vraiment des
coups plusieurs coups au visage et se
sont en témoigner la fracture du nez les
dents cassées un coup au fond il ya eu
plusieurs coups de poings et je sentais
bien que ça s'arrêtait pas attaques
violentes pourtant elle a souhaité
témoigner quand j'entends aujourd'hui
des fois des enseignants qui me disent
bas puisqu'ils étaient arrivés je fais
plus attention
j'en parle maintenant autour de moi je
veux dire des choses alors qu'avant josé
pas je suis pas là pour être un modèle
mais ça je me dis bon si au moins ça
peut servir à quelque chose se briser
les tabous démystifier les violences
scolaires verbales ou physiques
c'est justement l'objectif de ces
formateurs du centre des deux
établissements de l'académie de
versailles
qu'est ce qui est de l'ordre du
prévisible de la provocation ou du défi
aujourd'hui ils interviennent auprès de
jeunes professeurs première année
d'enseignement pour certains en zone
violence et beaucoup d'interrogations
j'étais en train d'écrire au tableau je
me suis refait un projectile dans leur
mon plâtre
là où j'étais en ce temps milliers
d'heures j'avais encore une heure de
cours à gérer qu'est ce que je fais qu
est ce que je me retire
comment faire comment je dois réagir
mais pas préparé du 3 1 l'élève qui
garde sa casquette entre le projectile
insultes perturbations entre avec ce
petit jeu de cartes on décrypte les
situations susceptibles de dégénérer
plus au lieu dit plus la vis sur sa tête
alors on va mettre en l'air tout le
court pour le cercueil moi j pamina
colin j'aimerais qu'à pratiquer cette
enseignante a dû gérer des gestes
obscènes d'ansac la voit faire ça le
l'explicité face pour 2,7 problème fait
et on le traite pas du tout on voit que
le problème c'est qu'on l'en pire des
caisses qu'il faudrait pouvoir
talisman rangèrent les situations
conflictuelles toujours à l'extérieur
atlas et a poussé à vous avez donné
suite à chaque dérapage s'appuie sur le
règlement et le reste de l'équipe
pas de recette miracle l'important c'est
d'y avoir pensé avant connaître c'est
avoir une réponse qui sera plus adapté
et de pas être justement dans ce qu'on
appelle le passage à l'acte c'est à dire
saisir un élève avoir un comportement
qui sera directement
qui va générer là pour le coup un
événement grave gestion des conflits
psychologie des adolescents ces
enseignants repartent avec quelques clés
mais la prévention tarde à s'imposer
dans leur cursus
or selon les spécialistes un professeur
bien formés cours deux fois moins le
risque d'être agressés l'actualité à
l'étranger d'abord ce gros coup de
déprime à londres capitale de la finance
frappé de plein fouet par la crise du
crédit les fameux golden boys sont sur
la sellette et se retrouve au chômage du
jour au lendemain entre 10000 et 40
mille postes devraient être supprimés
sur place maryse burgot laurent des bois
quartier des affaires de londres
ambiance aussi morose que le ciel des
milliers de financiers empruntent chaque
matin ce pont pour aller à la city mais
depuis le début de l'année quatre mille
d'entre eux ont déjà été licenciés
ceux là sont nés trop pressés pour en
parler
une bonne excuse la question de raconter
ces centaines de licenciements
expéditives réglé en 15 minutes avec
départ sur le champ par une porte
arrière pour ne pas saper le moral des
autres
on savait en un quart d'heure on arrive
le matin
on se connecte à l'ordinateur donc on
sait qu'on est bien
dix mille à 40000 emplois de trader's ou
autres sont menacés dans ces grandes
banques
conséquence directe de la crise du
crédit aux états unis dans cette salle
de marché cet après midi ses traders ne
sont pas autorisés à évoquer ces
licenciements dans la city mais ils le
savent l'inflation la baisse de
consommation des ménages et la crise
immobilière sont de mauvais si le
problème c'est que les perspectives sont
incertaines les prévisions de croissance
ont jamais été aussi peu optimiste
une consolation pour ses financiers
s'ils perdent leur emploi ils en
retrouverons un autre relativement
facilement
le ralentissement de l'économie
britannique n'ayant pas encore provoquer
de crise de l'emploi
une décision attendue en matière
d'adoption internationale la chanteuse
madonna a finalement obtenu le feu vert
du malawi pour devenir la mère du petit
david ce garçon aujourd'hui âgé de près
de 3 ans l'enfant a toujours un père et
certains avaient accusé la vedette de
l'avoir acheté entre guillemets avec des
dons elle a finalement obtenu gain de
cause
karine comazzi c'était il ya un an et
demi la ville était encore un petit
malawite
orphelin de mère abandonnée par son père
aujourd'hui sa mère adoptive s'appelle
madonna et l'enfant de 3 ans fait
définitivement partie du portrait de
famille car après dix-huit mois de garde
temporaire le tribunal de lilongwe au
malawi a accordé l'adoption à la
chanteuse une décision merveilleuse et
positif pour l'adoption en mal a déclaré
son avocat et pour la chanteuse
c'est la fin d'un long bras de fer à
l'époque le père de david avait protesté
l'adoption même s'il avait confié son
enfant à l'orphelinat
car il avait suffi d'une visite de
charité de quelques jours à peine pour
que madonna obtienne la garde temporaire
alors que la loi impose 18 mois de
résidence dans le pays
la star blessé s'en est expliqué sur les
chaînes de td c'est quelqu'un m'avait
dit son père vient le voir toutes les
semaines où sa grand-mère lui rend
visite régulièrement et sans le cube
bien je n'aurai plus penser à lui
madonna at elle bénéficié d'un régime de
faveur c'est le père de l'enfant qui
aujourd'hui met fin aux discussions
mais aucun problème avec la décision de
la justice de permettre à madonna
d'obtenir lambert c'est ce que j'ai
voulu que madonna garde l'enfant s'il
vit aujourd'hui en angleterre avec une
star le petit d'hab il pourra choisir sa
famille à sa majorité
en bref la birmanie tient ses promesses
même si le processus est lent elle a
ouvert aux humanitaires étrangers le
delta le plus touchée par le cyclone
les organisations elles mêmes le
confirme en revanche pierre la junte a
décidé de maintenir à l'isolément
l'opposante aung san suu kyi
une victoire commerciale pour les états
unis
la commission européenne a décidé
d'autoriser l'importation de poulets
américains désinfectés à la javel
c'est très courant là bas mais la
pratique est controversé en europe 21
ministres de l'agriculture sur 27
ils sont d'ailleurs opposés seule
condition l'étiquetage devra être très
précis la thalie sa peña parce qu'elle
joue friot volent bas de combat sur ce
marché parisien ici les poulets chlorés
en provenance des états unis
personne n'en veut s'associer à nous
aujourd'hui les gens ce qu'ils
recherchent et la zone marchande
c'est pas des poulets chlorés ou des
poulets patrie des choses la raison de
ses inquiétudes
bruxelles veut autoriser l'importation
de ces poulets américains des poulets
qui sont plongés dans un bain d'eau
chlorée pour les débarrasser de germes
comme la salmonelle un traitement
interdit depuis 11 ans en europe
à l'opposé des pratiques françaises chez
nous pas de bain chimique mais un
refroidissement à 3 degrés pourtant à
new york dans ce restaurant français
on ne comprend pas la polémique il
voulait lui rincer à l'eau normale de je
vous invite à visionner vous allez voir
aucun rouge bord pour l'instant ce n'est
qu'une proposition
les états membres de l'union européenne
devront se prononcer et 21 sur 27 dont
la france ont déjà dit non la france
précisément avec le retournement de
l'immobilier en avait beaucoup parlé de
la hausse de ces dernières années eh
bien les derniers chiffres le montrent
le marché du neuf s'est effondré au
premier trimestre 2008
il faut désormais près d'un an pour
vendre une maison
fabien shadow bernie mériaux françoise
blanc recherche un quatre pièces en
région bordelaise pour s'y installer
avec son mari seulement avant de signer
elle veut prendre son temps
finie l'époque où les acheteurs signé
les yeux fermés les uns après les autres
les clignotants de l'immobilier passe
dans le rouge
les ventes de logements neufs ont reculé
de presque 30% en un an
18 régions sur 22 sont concernés ce sont
les zones rurales les plus touchées avec
des baisses qui peuvent atteindre 68 %
il faut désormais un an pour vendre un
bien contre neuf mois l'année dernière
principale explication les investisseurs
se détournent des dispositifs de
défiscalisation type borloo ou robien
qui représentait mais d'une vente sur
deux en 2006 beaucoup d'investisseurs de
nouveaux investisseurs dans l'immobilier
acheter des appartements je dirais en
tant que produits financiers donc sans
forcément voir les le bien final même
l'emplacement
aujourd'hui ces investissements
déçoivent beaucoup de propriétaires
n'ont pas de locataire et se retrouvent
avec leur logement sur les bras sans
pouvoir les revendre comme les stocks
augmentent et promoteurs en plus en plus
de mal à vendre les appartements qui
sont en cours de construction ou en
projet forcément ça va peser sur les
prix et les ménages vont eux attendre
puisqu'ils se disent que les prix vont
baisser donc ils n'ont aucune raison
d'acheter maintenant ce qui va
entretenir le marché immobilier à la
baisse selon ses prévisions
les prix devraient baisser de 4% cette
année et de 6 % l'an prochain
les grandes manoeuvres dans l'industrie
on reparle de la fusion entre gaz de
france et suez gaz de france dans le
comité central d'entreprise a rendu son
avis ce mariage est dans
r depuis des mois pour donner naissance
à un géant de l'énergie quels en sont
les enjeux quels en sont les modalités
jean-paul chapelle et emmanuel bec ont
pu suivre les deux pdg c'est assez rare
voici le reportage sur la fusion la
fusion ça fait près de trois ans qu'ils
l'attendent à gauche gaz de france à
droite suez fusionner deux entreprises
c'est d'abord réunir deux équipes
les électriciens de suez 90000 personnes
les gaziers de gdf cinq ans tenir
ensemble un des premiers groupes
énergétiques européens
le projet initial a été modifié par
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui pour les
deux pdg le partage du pouvoir est clair
un leader mondial spécialisé dans
l'énergie
bah c'est le chef de chacun son style
y compris à la buvette verre de rouge au
gaz de france une bière pour suel non
mais j'y tiens beaucoup à chaque
entreprise sa culture
pas facile chez gaz de france
entreprises publiques de convaincre les
syndicats de l'intérêt de cette
privatisation n'y voit pas un projet
social il n'y voit pas un produit
industriel syrien ne voient plutôt un
projet initié et sa singh et mais je me
demande pourquoi vous dites ça parce que
projet social n'y a pas de réduction
d'emplois
y a pas de plan social on est une vraie
d'entreprise qui va embaucher
c'est ça qui est vraiment changé par
rapport côté direction le raisonnement
est simple
en fusionnant on est plus forts pour
négocier quand il s'agit d'acheter du
gaz à l'étranger
pendant ce temps le patron de suez tente
de rassurer ses clients ici des pme en
lorraine
l'ouverture de la concurrence dont le
marché de l'électricité n'a pas fait
baisser les prix quand on retrouve si
vous voulez
ah cool d'énergie plus important que les
autres marha c pas de solution miracle
l'énergie restera cher malgré la fusion
cette fusion c'est lui qui en a eu
l'idée
la réunion des forces de suez et de gaz
de france
internet de constituer vraiment un
groupe extrêmement puissant capable de
répondre aux grands enjeux de
l'approvisionnement énergétique mais
aussi du réchauffement climatique
la photo de famille est plus que prête
le nouveau groupe devrait être
opérationnel cet été économie et justice
dans l' enquête sur de possibles délits
d'initiés au sein du groupe eads noël
forgeard ancien co-président est
actuellement en garde à vue il avait été
convoqué par la police en fin de matinée
pour être entendues dans ce dossier la
france épinglée par la commission
européenne pour ses déficits bruxelles
émet une recommandation politique une
sorte de réprimande
nicolas sarkozy ici en visite en pologne
a réagi ils contestent les prévisions de
bruxelles
on écoute nous avons une différence
d'interprétation sur les chiffres de la
commission qui touche aux déclarations
de monsieur almunia dont vous savez
parfaitement bien que les chiffres de la
commission ont été scrupuleusement
démentie par les chiffres que vient de
publier l'insee qui est un organisme
indépendant vous connaissez et donc les
hypothèses de la commission sont basées
sur des chiffres qui ne sont pas
vérifiées qui ont même été démentie
propos recueillis par philippe turpault
un mode politique encore les
parlementaires socialistes annoncent
qu'ils vont quitter la commission copé
sur la télévision publique
il est la personnalité préférée des
français mais il annonce qu'il va
quitter l'hexagone yannick noah va
s'installer à new york alors qu'on fête
les 25 ans de sa victoire à roland
garros
il nous dira pourquoi dans un instant
d'abord reportage à beauvais où il était
en déplacement pour son association
julien benedetto antonin broutards une
leçon de tennis gratuite dispensée par
yannick noah en personne a fuit le match
on se faire la main
lajoux et mademoiselle comment je
m'appelle journée inoubliable pour les
enfants du quartier de la soie vauban à
bové avant de quitter la france le
champion chanteur vient réparer une
injustice car ici personne n'a les
moyens de s'inscrire dans un club de
tennis et gratuit on nous prête les
cours on prêtait raquette en fait
l'accessible à tout le monde quoi
construire des courts de tennis dans les
quartiers défavorisés
c'est le défi de l'association présidée
par yannick noah les cours sont ouverts
jour et nuit
l'association prête des raquettes
objectif démocratiser la pratique du
tennis
je fais comme si j'enseigne à mes
enfants
ce que le mien parce que pas du tout
désormais les apparitions de noah sur
les courts de son association risquent
de se faire plus rares il part vivre aux
états unis
gloria nick novak est en duplex avec
nous de beauvais merci et bon soir
yannick noah première chose vous
confirmer que vous allez quitter la
france pour vous installer à new york
pendant au moins deux ans pourquoi la
nouvelle du jour
je confirme je confiais dont je vais
passer une année scolaire avec mes
enfants je vais rassembler ma famille
comme vous le savez j'ai une partie de
ma famille nous un marmaille qui vit aux
états unis entre joachim à chicago il
est né à new york
donc ça n'a aucun rapport avec la
politique on s'occupait des associations
parce que vous aviez indiqué en donné
que la sarkozy était élu vous envisagiez
de quitter la france
non non il n'y a rien de politique là
dedans enfin disons que ça m'a pas aidé
bon on vous a vu à roland garros pour
les 25 ans de votre victoire dans le
tournoi depuis c'est un peu la disette
pourquoi est ce que les champions
français n'y arrive pas est-ce qu'ils
sont trop gâtés parce qu'on vous a
entendu dire un peu ça c'est sûr que
lorsqu'on voit les le parcours des deux
joueurs de tennis en rien
en général chez nous ce sont des enfants
et des gamins qui viennent de deux
familles relativement aisé classe
moyenne
et du coup c'est vrai que quand il
s'agit de faire des efforts importants
et des sacrifices ça peut être difficile
bon là bien entendu je généralise
mais même sans gagner bons joueurs et
beaucoup de beaucoup de bons choix
je pense qu'il faut avoir faim oui je
pense qu'à un moment il faut avoir fait
une petite cassure il faut être
légèrement habité faut être un peu fou
et nous on aime nos joueurs soient un
petit peu trop normaux c'est pas mal non
plus alors vous avez italien inauguré
une nouvelle installation pour votre
association
en quoi est ce que le sport peut être
important pour donner de la vie dans
l'est dans les quartiers dans le sport
est important tout court je je pousse
les enfants à faire du sport il se
trouve que j'ai pas mal de temps en
dehors de mes activités j'ai du temps et
je pense qu'il est nécessaire pour les
enfants d'avoir l'opportunité d'être
encadré de temps en temps au tour d'une
aire de jeux une aire de sport et
surtout pour les enfants qui n'ont pas
forcément la chance de nos enfants voilà
le tennis est un sport qui est
magnifique mais qui reste encore un
petit peu un petit peu cher alors c'est
au père que je m'adresse et je vous en
reparle puisque vous en avait parlé dans
la presse votre fils joakim va passer
devant la justice américaine parce qu'il
a été trouvé avec un joint une cigarette
de cannabis dans la poche ou l'avait
réprimandé où vous l'avez consoler j'ai
parlé à joachim juste après cet incident
celui qui m'a appelé il se trouve que
oui il va voir une contravention
je trouve que cet incident est passé sur
internet et depuis depuis passant en
justice il est sur le point d'aller de
passer en d'aller en prison mais ça
s'est il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de
bruit en france assez étonnant bon je
lui ai dit que ce n'était pas la
meilleure chose qui pouvait faire que
c'était plutôt une boulette mais que
métis en face pas que forcément il y
avoir des gens qui allaient s'engouffrer
là dedans et qu'on allait lui en parler
pendant un petit moment mais c'est la
loi c'est la règle du jeu voilà c'est un
garçon qui maintenant énormément
médiatisé et quand il va faire des
choses belles ça va être extraordinaire
et puis quand il fera des bullets avait
des catastrophes alors il est fait et il
a fait une petite boulette 1 voilà merci
à yannick noah pour cet entretien
enregistré
cet après midi un mot des matches du
jour à roland garros avec un sort
contrasté pour les français victoire de
bénéteau de santoro de gicquel ou encore
et si paul henri mathieu après cinq sets
face à l'espagnol hernandez
défaite en revanche de simon mahut et
surtout de la numéro un française marion
bartoli c'est une grosse déception
elle s'est inclinée face à
l'australienne dellacqua voici la balle
de match
les principaux favoris nadal notamment
longtemps porté les images chine et
chloé cormery football avec la sélection
française pour l'euro 2008
retenez bien ce nom bafé gomis
l'attaquant de saint-etienne 22 ans
seulement étincelant hier soir face à
l'équateur est retenu par raymond
domenech c'est la surprise cissé et
landreau ne sont pas sélectionnés manuel
tissier andré germe la panthère verte a
dévoré la concurrence pas fait team dit
gomis le buteur de saint-etienne pouces
djibril cissé hors de l'euro la nouvelle
est considérable mais depuis hier soir
cet appel d'une surprise l'attaquant de
22 ans a éclaboussé le premier match de
préparation des bleus
gomis comme i dames il ya 14 ans a
marqué deux fois pour sa première
sélection le but splendide que raymond
domenech ne pouvait ignorer à quelques
heures de publier la liste de ses 23
joueurs pour l'euro 2008
un choix douloureux pour sept joueurs et
un sélectionneur j'ai essayé de rester
professionnel j'avoue que pour certains
j'ai pas pu je vous citerai pas de noms
mais que voilà j'ai été dans l'affectif
plus que dans le professionnel mais bon
c'est comme ça
au dessus de tignes raymond domenech a
organisé une véritable opération
aéroportée pour préserver les exclus
loin des caméras et des photographes
les sept joueurs congédié ont embarqué
peu avant 14 heures cissé et landreau
invisible on distingue à peine les
traits de ben arfa et la casquette de
julien escudé
les vacances ont un goût amer
faudra être costaud mentalement parce
que c'est très difficile de se relever
de ça parce que c'est le président
carrière on sait jamais comment ça peut
se passer et de nous faire un euro je me
suis c'est très dur dispensé
d'entraînement gomis et les acteurs du
match d'hier n'ont pas chaussé les
crampons cet après midi ils sont bien 23
en route vers l'euro avant de refermer
ce journal je vous en rappelle l'un des
principaux titres michel fourniret a été
condamné à la perpétuité incompressible
cet après-midi la peine maximale du code
pénal perpétuité également pour son
épouse monique olivier avec 28 ans de
période de sûreté
fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi tout de suite la météo laurent
romejko 20h50 faites entrer l'accusé
avec christophe hondelatte à demain
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr